Durch den Tod von Stephen Hawkings im März
diesen Jahres haben wir ein brillantes Genie
auf der Welt weniger.
Seine Gedanken haben nicht nur Physikerinnen
und Physiker fasziniert, sondern auch Laien,
die mit diesen Themen eigentlich nichts am
Hut hatten.
Er war quasi der Popstar in der Wissenschaft!
Eines kann ich verraten: Es geht um Schwarze
Löcher und die Evolution des Universums!
Herzlich willkommen bei Clixoom Science & Fiction
und wie gesagt: Danke für Euren super spannenden
Themenvorschlag!
Ich persönlich habe mich sehr gefreut, dass
ihr Euch in unser Whats App Community gerade
dieses Thema gewünscht habt.
„Ich möchte das Universum ganz und gar
verstehen.
(...) Ich möchte wissen, warum es so ist,
wie es ist, und warum es überhaupt existiert.“
Dieses Zitat von Stephen Hawking beschreibt
wohl perfekt seine Ziele und ja: Er hat einen
sehr großen Teil dazu beigetragen, dass wir
heute das wissen, was wir eben wissen.
Schwarze Löcher
Schwarze Löcher sind wohl DER Grund, warum
Stephen Hawking auch weit über seinen Forschungsbereich
bekannt wurde.
Stellt Euch das mal vor: Schon 1971 hat der
theoretische Physiker eine Theorie zum Verschmelzen
von zwei Schwarzen Löchern aufgestellt.
Doch erst im Jahr 2016, also 45 Jahre später,
konnte seine Vorhersage auch im Experiment
bewiesen werden.
Demnach ist die Oberfläche des neuen Objektes
größer als die Summe der beiden Oberflächen
der Ausgangs-Objekte.
Das Krasse daran: Stephen Hawking beschäftigte
sich schon mit Schwarzen Löchern, als es
nicht einmal Beobachtungsdaten dazu gab.
Der Physiker dachte quasi “nur” mithilfe
seines eigenen Gehirns, Papier und Bleistift
darauf rum und kam so zu der Erkenntnis, dass
Schwarze Löcher keineswegs eine Einbahnstraße
sind, sondern laut den Naturgesetzen verdampfen
müssen.
Zu der sogenannten Hawking-Strahlung komme
ich gleich noch viel ausführlicher, jedenfalls
folgt aus dieser Überlegung auch das sogenannte
Informationsparadoxon.
Der Fachbegriff für den folgenden Widerspruch:
Geht es nach Einsteins Relativitätstheorie
müsste Materie beim Überschreiten des Ereignishorizonts
eines Schwarzen Lochs verschwinden - und zwar
gemeinsam mit der von der Materie transportieren
Information, die dann für immer verloren
wäre.
Die Quantenmechanik dagegen sieht das anders:
Demnach kann eine Information nicht vernichtet
werden.
Dazu schreibt Hawking im Jahr 2013: “Die
Information geht nicht verloren, sie wird
nur nicht in brauchbarer Weise zurückerstattet.
Es ist so, als würden Sie eine Enzyklopädie
verbrennen: Streng genommen geht die in ihr
enthaltene Information nicht verloren, wenn
Sie allen Rauch und alle Asche sorgfältig
aufheben, aber sie lässt sich sehr schwer
lesen."
Noch im Oktober diesen Jahres war eine Arbeit
von Hawking zu Schwarzen Löchern veröffentlicht
worden, die er wohl kurz vor seinem Tod erstellt
hatte - wir hatten darüber bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction berichtet.
Und auch hier beschäftigte er sich mit dem
sogenannten Informationsparadoxon.
Hawking hat sich sein ganzes Leben lang mit
Schwarzen Löchern beschäftigt.
Seiner Meinung nach haben Schwarze Löcher
nicht nur Masse, Ladung und einen Drehimpuls,
sondern auch Temperatur.
Somit müssten sie Wärme in den Weltraum
abgeben und am Ende ganz verdampfen, so Hawking.
Wo geht also die Information hin, wenn ein
Schwarzes Loch verdampft und mit ihm alle
Objekte, die es eingesaugt hat?
In seiner letzten Arbeit hat Hawking dafür
einen Lösungsansatz präsentiert, der erklären
könnte, wie zumindest ein Teil der Information
eben NICHT verloren geht, sondern erhalten
bleibt.
Im Mittelpunkt dieser Überlegungen steht
die Entropie, womit quasi der Grad der Unordnung
beschrieben wird eine Ausprägung von Information.
Wenn also ein Objekt in einem Schwarzen Loch
verschwindet, steigt sowohl seine Temperatur
als auch die Entropie.
Diese könnte ggf. mit Photonen, also Lichtteilchen,
erfasst werden, die den Ereignishorizont des
Schwarzen Lochs umkreisen, womit Information
erfasst würde.
Leider ist damit das Informationsparadoxon
noch nicht gelöst, denn immer noch nicht
ist klar, ob die Entropie alles widerspiegelt,
was in einem Schwarzen Loch landet.
2.
Der Urknall: Das Universum hat einen Anfang!
Hawking schloss seine Doktorarbeit im Jahr
1966 ab und schon zu dieser Zeit war ihm die
Aufmerksamkeit seiner ganzen Kollegen gewiss.
Denn damals hatte er einzig und allein aus
Einsteins Relativitätstheorie abgeleitet,
dass das Universum einen Anfang haben muss.
An der Urknall-Theorie hatte der Großteil
der Fachwelt vorher bezweifelt, mittlerweile
ist die “Big Bang”-Theorie längst etabliert.
Hawking hatte die Erkenntnis, dass die Zeit
erst mit dem Urknall in die Welt gekommen
sein konnte.
Und die Evolution des Weltalls war wohl neben
den Schwarzen Löchern Hawkings große Leidenschaft.
Unter anderem erkannte er, das sich die Singularität
im Urknall und einem Schwarzen Loch gleichen.
Seiner Ansicht nach kann das gesamte Universum
aus einer Singularität entstanden sein - ein
großer Stern kann demnach aber auch zu einer
Singularität zusammenstürzen.
Das gibt die Allgemeine Relativitätstheorie
jedoch nicht her, denn danach müsste das
Universum eigentlich einen Anfang haben.
Doch auch dafür hatte Hawking dann eine Lösung
parat.
Eine Art imaginäre Zeit, die ihren Anfang
am Südpol hat.
Somit kann der Anfang des Universums auf den
Südpol einer Kugelfläche gelegt werden.
Die Singularität wird damit vermieden.
Denn das Universum ist damit in sich geschlossen
- wie eine Kugelfläche eben, die auch keinen
Rand hat.
Diese Überlegung von Hawking wird oft als
die “Kein-Rand-Hypothese” bezeichnet und
ist seiner Ansicht nach “der Schlüssel
zur Schöpfung, zur Antwort auf die Frage,
warum wir hier sind”.
Auf den Punkt gebracht wäre der Urknall gar
kein Urknall, sondern eben der Südpol unseres
Universums, womit es eben den Urknall nicht
als Anfang gäbe, sondern er ein Punkt auf
einer Kugel wäre.
Das Universum wäre dann auch in der Zeitdimension
eine Kugel und es gäbe keinen Anfang und
kein Ende.
Das ist wirklich verrückt.
Ich denke mir gerne mal so mein Leben.
Es ist eine Einheit und nichts ist “vorbei”.
das ist dann letztlich sogar nur eine Illusion.
3.
Die Hawking-Strahlung
Seine Erkenntnisse zu Schwarzen Löchern und
der sogenannten Hawking-Strahlung sind vielleicht
der Paukenschlag überhaupt des brillanten
Genies’.
Hawking nämlich erkannte, dass die oft als
Staubsauger bezeichneten Schwarzen Löcher
nicht nur Materie verschlucken.
Bis dahin nahm die Fachwelt an, dass Schwarzen
Löchern nichts, einfach gar nicht entkommen
kann.
Doch der Physiker zeigte, dass sie Strahlung
aussenden und letztendlich langsam verdampfen,
bis sie dann irgendwann verschwunden sind.
Heißt also: Schwarze Löcher halten nicht
bis in alle Ewigkeit.
Und das waren tatsächlich nicht nur überraschende,
sondern sogar revolutionäre Erkenntnisse!
Diese Strahlung wurde dann einige Zeit später
als “Hawking-Strahlung” benannt.
Der Physiker ging sogar davon aus, dass es
irgendwann einmal ein Zeitalter geben wird,
in dem im Weltall keine Schwarzen Löcher
gibt.
Was jedenfalls besonders faszinierend an seinen
Überlegungen zur Hawking Strahlung ist, ist,
dass sie durch die Anwendung der Quantenmechanik
erst möglich wird.
Schwarze Löcher dagegen entstehen durch Überlegungen
der Allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie.
Der größte Traum der Physik ist es, diese
beiden Theorien zusammenzubringen.
Eine große Herausforderungen in diesem Zusammenhang:
Experimentell konnte die Hawking-Strahlung
bisher noch nicht nachgewiesen werden.
Dies gestaltet sich als schwierig, weil sich
Schwarze Löcher zum einen in astronomischen
Distanzen finden und die Hawking-Strahlung
wohl eine sehr geringe Intensität hat.
Zudem könnten andere Strahlungseffekte in
der Umgebung des Lochs diesen Effekt überwiegen.
So ist der Nachweis der Hawking-Strahlung
bei echten Schwarzen Löchern wohl fast unmöglich.
Doch moderne Teilchenbeschleuniger könnten
das Unmögliche möglich machen - wenn es
gelingt, Schwarze Löcher künstlich im Labor
herzustellen.
Wow.
Das wäre wirklich revolutionär.
Aber keine Angst.
Jedes Objekt ist quasi ein Schwarzes Loch,
es hat einen Schwarzschildradius, in dessen
Bereich alles in sich zusammenfällt.
Allerdings ist er dann immer so klein, das
eben kein Schwarzes Loch entsteht.
Bei der der Erde zum Beispiel 8,8 Millimeter
und bei der Sonne drei Kilometer.
Dementsprechend sind eben auch Schwarze Minilöcher
vollkommen ungefährlich.
Aber es wäre der Hammer, wenn eich solches
Loch erzeugt werden könnte und dann die Hawking-Strahlung
gemessen werden könnte.
Wow.
Wenn es soweit ist, werden wir natürlich
darüber berichten.
Wenn ihr dieses Video dann nicht und auch
allen anderen Videos verpassen wollt, dann
abonniert Clixoom auch auf englisch.
Denn auch da gibt es immer wieder Videopremieren.
Dafür einfach hier draufklicken.
Und hier geht es weiter mit: Mankind lives
in two Galaxies!
Bis bald hoffentlich auch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
See you soon, stay tuned!